ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ความเข้าใจเรื่องข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ ฉันชื่อ John Watrous และเป็นผู้อำนวยการฝ่ายเทคนิคด้านการศึกษาที่ IBM
Quantum นี่คือบทเรียนที่ 12 ในซีรีส์นี้ และเป็นบทเรียนสุดท้ายในหน่วยที่สาม ซึ่งเป็นเรื่อง
การกำหนดสูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัม บทเรียนนี้เน้นที่ notion พื้นฐานในข้อมูลควอนตัม ซึ่งคือ
purification ของ quantum state purification ของ quantum state ที่แสดงโดย density matrix บางตัวคือ
pure state ของ compound system ที่ใหญ่กว่า ซึ่งทิ้ง state ต้นฉบับไว้เมื่อส่วนที่เหลือของ compound system ถูก
ทิ้งหรือ trace out ทุก density matrix มี purification และเราสามารถเรียนรู้มาก
เกี่ยวกับ quantum states และ quantum information โดยทั่วไปโดยการศึกษา purifications ในระดับ intuitive
quantum state vectors ซึ่งแสดง pure states เป็น mathematical objects ที่ง่ายกว่า density matrices และโดยการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
purifications ของ states เราสามารถมองว่า quantum states ของ systems ที่ arbitrary เป็นแค่ส่วนหนึ่งของบางสิ่งที่ใหญ่กว่าแต่
ง่ายกว่า เราจะพูดถึง fidelity ระหว่าง quantum states สองตัวด้วย ซึ่งเป็นค่าที่ quantify ความคล้ายคลึงหรือ overlap ของพวกมัน
และมักใช้เป็นวิธีวัดว่า state หนึ่งดีแค่ไหนเมื่อเทียบกับ
ideal state โดยเฉพาะเราจะพูดถึง definition ของ fidelity พร้อมกับคุณสมบัติพื้นฐานบางอย่าง และเราจะเห็น
วิธีที่ fidelity เชื่อมต่อกับ purifications นี่คือภาพรวมของบทเรียน เราจะเริ่มด้วย purifications รวมถึง
definition และ proof ง่ายๆ ของการมีอยู่ ซึ่งบอกเราวิธีหาหนึ่งถ้าต้องการ จากนั้นเราจะพูดถึงสิ่งที่เรียกว่า
Schmidt decomposition ของ quantum state vector ของสองระบบ และเราจะเห็นว่า Schmidt decompositions เชื่อมต่อกับ
purifications อย่างไร จากนั้นเราจะพูดถึงความสัมพันธ์สำคัญมากระหว่าง purifications ใดๆ สองตัวของ state เดียวกัน ซึ่งรู้จักกันในชื่อ unitary
equivalence ของ purifications และสุดท้ายเราจะผ่านตัวอย่างบางส่วน แล้วเราไปที่ fidelity
รวมถึง definition และคุณสมบัติพื้นฐานบางส่วน เราจะพูดถึง gentle measurement lemma ซึ่งเป็นข้อเท็จจริงที่ handy มากที่เชื่อม fidelity
กับการวัด และสุดท้ายเพื่อสรุปบทเรียน เราจะไปที่ Uhlmann's theorem ซึ่ง
สร้างการเชื่อมต่อพื้นฐานระหว่าง fidelity และ purifications มาเริ่มกับ
definition ของ purification purification ของ state ซึ่งสมมติว่าแสดงโดย density
matrix คือ pure state ของ compound system ที่ใหญ่กว่า ซึ่งทิ้ง state ต้นฉบับที่เราเริ่มต้นเมื่อส่วนที่เหลือ
ของ compound system ถูก trace out เราสามารถแสดงสิ่งนี้ได้ชัดเจนขึ้นในรูปแบบทางคณิตศาสตร์
ดังต่อไปนี้ ถ้าเรามีระบบ X ที่อยู่ใน state row ซึ่งหมายความว่า row เป็น density matrix แสดง state ของ X
และ S เป็น quantum state vector ของคู่ระบบ XY เช่นว่าการ trace out Y จาก pure state Psi ket plus I
ทิ้ง row ไว้ เราก็บอกว่า S เป็น purification ของ row ชื่อไม่สำคัญ เรา
สามารถตั้งชื่อระบบและ states ได้ตามที่ต้องการ และลำดับของระบบก็ไม่สำคัญเช่นกัน ตัวอย่างเช่น
ถ้าระบบ Y อยู่ทางซ้ายแทนที่จะเป็นทางขวา แต่ทุกอย่างอื่นเหมือนกัน เราก็ยังเรียก Psi ว่าเป็น purification ของ row แต่เรา
จะยึดกับการตั้งค่านี้เป็นหลักตลอดบทเรียนเพื่อความเรียบง่าย และสิ่งแรกที่จะพูดถึง
definition คือ purifications มีอยู่เสมอสำหรับทุก density matrix row และให้ชัดเจนยิ่งขึ้น ทุก density
matrix row มี purification ตามที่ definition อธิบาย ตราบเท่าที่ระบบ Y ใหญ่อย่างน้อยเท่ากับ X ซึ่ง
หมายความว่า Y มี classical states อย่างน้อยเท่าๆ กับ X notion ของ purification และ
ข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า purifications มีอยู่เสมอกลายเป็นสิ่งสำคัญมาก และยังเป็นส่วนหนึ่งของสิ่งที่ทำให้ quantum information สวยงามและหวังว่า
ฉันจะสามารถโน้มน้าวให้คุณเห็นข้อเท็จจริงนั้นก่อนสิ้นสุดบทเรียน ตอนนี้มาพิสูจน์ว่าทุก density matrix มี purification และใน
กระบวนการเราจะเห็นวิธีหา purification เมื่อต้องการ เหมือนกับที่เรามีใน definition
ของ purification สมมติว่า X เป็นระบบและ row เป็น density matrix แสดง state ของ
X ตอนนี้พิจารณา expression ใดๆ ของ row เป็น convex combination ของ pure states ดังที่เราเขียนบนหน้าจอ ใน words
สำหรับตัวเลือกบางอย่างของ integer บวก n เรามี probability vector P 0 ถึง PN ลบ 1 รวมถึง quantum
state vectors fi 0 ถึง fi ลบ 1 และโดยการ average pure states ที่สอดคล้องกัน weighted ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น เรา
ได้ row ตัวอย่างเช่น เราสามารถใช้ spectral theorem เพื่อรับ expression ของ row แบบนี้ และถ้าเราทำเช่นนั้น เรา
สามารถ take n เป็นจำนวน classical states ของ X ที่จริงเราสามารถ take n เป็น rank ของ row ซึ่งคือ
จำนวน eigenvalues ที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์ของ row นับแต่ละอันหลายครั้งเท่ากับ multiplicity และ
นั่นไม่เคยใหญ่กว่าจำนวน classical states ของ X แต่อาจเล็กกว่า ในทางกลับกันนี่
ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น spectral decomposition ของ row และเราไม่ต้องการ quantum state vectors เหล่านี้ให้ orthogonal ตัวอย่างเช่น expression ใดๆ ของ row แบบนี้
ก็ได้ และนี่คือ purification ของ row ผลรวมครอบคลุมค่าเดียวกันกับใน
expression ของ row และภายในผลรวม เรา take square roots ของความน่าจะเป็นคูณกับ phi A tensored
กับ ket A ที่นี่เราสมมติว่า 0 ถึง n ลบ 1 เป็น classical states ของ second system Y ดังนั้น
S จึง make sense ว่าเป็น quantum state vector ของคู่ XY เหมือนใน definition มันไม่สำคัญจริงๆ
ที่นี่ว่าเราใช้ standard basis states ของ Y ใน expression นี้ คุณสามารถแทนที่ orthonormal collection ใดๆ ของ
states แทน kets K 0 ถึง ket n ลบ 1 ถ้าต้องการ และตอนนี้เราสามารถตรวจสอบว่านี่เป็น
purification โดยคำนวณ partial trace ผ่าน Y นี่คือ expression ของ state ที่เราได้โดยทำ partial trace
trace ของ ket A bra B คือหนึ่งหรือศูนย์ขึ้นอยู่กับว่า A เท่ากับ B หรือไม่ ดังนั้น expression
simplify เป็น expression ต้นฉบับของ row และมันง่ายเท่านั้นเอง ดังนั้นมันง่ายมากในการหา
purification ตราบเท่าที่เรามี classical states ของ Y เพียงพอ หรืออีกทางหนึ่ง orthonormal set ที่ใหญ่พอที่จะใช้แทน
standard basis states ket 0 ถึง ket n ลบ 1 และโดยวิธี ถ้าจำนวน
classical states ของ Y เล็กกว่า rank ของ row ก็จะไม่มี purification และฉันจะปล่อยให้คุณ
คิดเรื่องนั้นถ้าต้องการ นี่คือตัวอย่าง ลองพิจารณา
density matrix ที่เราเห็นหลายครั้งในบทเรียนเรื่อง density matrices ที่นี่เรามี expression ของนี้
density matrix เป็น convex combination ของ pure states มันไม่ใช่ spectral decomposition แต่เรา
ไม่สนใจ และด้วยความพยายามแทบไม่มีเลย เราสามารถเขียน purification ของ state ได้โดยทำตาม
recipe นั่นไม่ใช่ purification เดียวของ density matrix นี้ purifications ไม่ unique แต่ก็โอเค
definition ไม่ได้พูดอะไรเกี่ยวกับความ unique และจริงๆ แล้วมีความสัมพันธ์ที่น่าสนใจมากระหว่าง purifications ต่างๆ ของ state เดียวกัน แต่
เราจะพูดถึงเรื่องนั้นในภายหลังในบทเรียน ต่อไปเราจะพิจารณา Schmidt decompositions ซึ่งเป็น expressions ของ
bipartite quantum state vectors ในรูปแบบหนึ่งที่ฉันจะอธิบายในอีกสักครู่ มันถูกตั้งชื่อตาม Erhard
Schmidt คนเดิมกับ Schmidt ที่รู้จักจาก Gram-Schmidt orthogonalization procedure แต่ในกรณีของ Schmidt decompositions มันน่าจะไม่ควร
ถูกตั้งชื่อตาม Schmidt จริงๆ แล้วมันเทียบเท่าทางคณิตศาสตร์กับสิ่งที่เรียกว่า singular value decomposition สำหรับ matrices ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่
ถูกค้นพบซ้ำหลายครั้ง แต่ก็เกิดขึ้นบางครั้ง ไม่ว่าจะอย่างไรก็ตาม นี่คือสิ่งที่เราหมายถึง
เมื่อเราอ้างถึง Schmidt decomposition สำหรับการเลือก quantum state vector S ใดๆ สำหรับคู่ของ
ระบบ XY มันเป็นไปได้เสมอที่จะเขียน S ในรูปแบบพิเศษ รูปแบบนั้นคือดังที่เรา
มีที่นี่บนหน้าจอ โดยที่ R เป็น integer บวกบางตัว p 0 ถึง p R ลบ 1 เป็นตัวเลขจริงบวกที่
รวมกันเป็น probability vector x0 ถึง xR ลบ 1 เป็น unit vectors สอดคล้องกับระบบ X และ y0
ถึง y R ลบ 1 เป็น unit vectors สอดคล้องกับระบบ Y ตอนนี้อาจดูไม่พิเศษมาก
จนกว่าฉันจะบอกว่าทั้งสองชุด x0 ถึง xR ลบ 1 และ y0 ถึง y R ลบ 1 ต้องเป็น
orthonormal แล้วทำไมถึงพิเศษ ถ้าเราเลือก basis ใดๆ สำหรับหนึ่งในสอง bases สมมติว่า
X vectors ที่สอดคล้องกับระบบ X เราก็สามารถแสดง S ในรูปแบบนี้เสมอ และนั่นจะบังคับให้เรา
เลือก Y vectors ในแบบหนึ่ง จริงๆ แล้วเราทำสิ่งนี้ค่อนข้างสม่ำเสมอ เช่นเดียวกับที่เราทำกับ standard basis เมื่อเรา
ตั้งตัวเองเพื่อวิเคราะห์การวัด standard basis แต่โดยทั่วไปแม้ว่าเราจะเลือก orthonormal basis สำหรับ
X vectors Y vectors ที่ได้ก็ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น orthonormal ในทำนองเดียวกันถ้าเราเลือก
orthonormal basis สำหรับ Y vectors และพยายามแสดง S ในรูปแบบอีกครั้ง ก็ทำได้ แต่ X vectors ก็จะ
ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น orthonormal และสุดท้ายถ้าเลือก orthonormal vectors สำหรับทั้งสองระบบ และ
พยายามแสดง S ในรูปแบบนี้ ก็อาจไม่ได้ผลเพราะอาจต้องการ cross terms บางอย่าง แต่มีแค่
index เดียวในผลรวมนี้คือ a ดังนั้นรูปแบบนี้พิเศษ แต่มันเป็นไปได้เสมอที่จะ
เขียน unit vector S ที่กำหนดแบบนี้ และนี่คือวิธีที่ทำได้ ก่อนอื่น compute spectral decomposition
สำหรับ reduced state ของระบบใดระบบหนึ่งก็ได้ ไม่สำคัญว่าจะเลือกอันไหน แต่เพื่อบอกวิธีทำ ดูที่ reduced state ของ
X ดังนั้นเรา trace out Y ซึ่งหมายความว่า p 0 ถึง p R ลบ 1 เป็น eigenvalues
ของ reduced state row นี้ และ x0 ถึง xR ลบ 1 เป็น unit eigenvectors ที่สอดคล้องกับ eigenvalues เหล่านี้ และ
โดยวิธี ความเข้าใจที่นี่คือเราละเว้น terms ที่ eigenvalues เป็นศูนย์เพราะ terms เหล่านั้นไม่มีส่วนใดๆ ต่อ
ผลรวม และนั่นหมายความว่า p 0 ถึง p R ลบ 1 ล้วนเป็นตัวเลขจริงบวก และ R คือจำนวน
eigenvalues ที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์นับ multiplicities ซึ่งเท่ากับ rank ของ row ดังนั้นนั่นให้เรา p 0 ถึง p R
ลบ 1 พร้อมกับ x0 ถึง xR ลบ 1 และสิ่งที่เหลืออยู่คือการหา vectors y0 ถึง y R
ลบ 1 มีแค่หนึ่งตัวเลือกที่อาจได้ผล vectors เหล่านั้นถูกกำหนดเพียงแบบเดียวในตอนนี้ และสามารถ
หาได้ง่ายโดยใช้ formula ง่ายๆ ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ และสิ่งที่น่าทึ่งที่นี่คือ
ถ้าเรา define vectors เหล่านี้แบบนี้ พวกมันรับประกันว่าจะเป็น orthonormal และนั่นให้เรา Schmidt decomposition ฉันจะไม่อธิบายใน
video นี้ แต่มันไม่ยากเกินไป และคุณสามารถดูเนื้อหาที่เป็นลายลักษณ์อักษรสำหรับบทเรียนได้ถ้าสนใจ
ดู description ของ video สำหรับ link ตามปกติ เป็นตัวอย่าง ลองพิจารณา
quantum state vector นี้ ซึ่งเราได้รับเป็น purification ของตัวอย่าง density matrix ที่เราวนกลับมาดู
มันไม่ใช่ Schmidt decomposition เพราะ zero และ plus states ไม่ orthonormal แต่เราสามารถหาได้
โดยใช้ procedure ที่ฉันอธิบายไป ขั้นตอนแรกคือ compute spectral decomposition สำหรับ reduced
state ของ X ซึ่งก็คือตัวอย่าง density matrix เดิม และนี่คือ spectral decomposition ของมัน ซึ่งเราเห็นใน
บทเรียนที่ 9 ดังนั้นเราเลือก p 0, P1, x0 และ X1 ตามที่
แสดงบนหน้าจอ p 0 และ P1 เป็น eigenvalues ของ row และ x0 และ X1 เป็น
unit eigenvectors ที่สอดคล้องกัน ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เหลือคือ compute y0 และ y1 และถ้าทำสิ่งนี้ เราได้ ket plus
สำหรับ y0 และ -1 คูณ ket minus สำหรับ y1 มันไม่ได้ชัดเจนทันที คุณต้อง
ทำการคำนวณจริงๆ เพื่อเห็นมัน แต่นั่นคือสิ่งที่ได้รับ และตามที่คาดไว้ vectors สองตัวนั้น orthonormal ดังที่
จะเป็นเสมอถ้าทำการคำนวณถูกต้อง และนั่นให้เรา Schmidt
decomposition Schmidt decompositions มีประโยชน์มากในหลายสถานการณ์ และในไม่ช้าเราจะเห็นว่ามันบอกเราอะไร
เกี่ยวกับ purifications purifications ไม่ unique quantum state ที่กำหนดซึ่งแสดงโดย
density matrix จะมี purifications อนันต์จริงๆ อย่างไรก็ตาม มีความสัมพันธ์ใกล้ชิด
ที่มีอยู่เสมอระหว่าง purifications สองตัวใดๆ ของ state เดียวกัน และบางครั้งเรียกว่า unitary
equivalence ของ purifications นี่คือวิธีที่มันทำงาน ให้ row เป็น density matrix
แสดง quantum state ของระบบ X และสมมติว่าเรามี purifications สองตัวใดๆ ของ state นั้นที่เป็น
pure states ของ compound system เดียวกัน ดังนั้นเพื่อความชัดเจน สมมติว่า S และ fi
เป็น quantum state vectors ของคู่ระบบ XY ที่ทั้งคู่ให้ row เมื่อ trace out ระบบ Y
สิ่งที่ unitary equivalence ของ purification บอกคือต้องมี unitary operation U ที่กระทำเฉพาะบน
ระบบ Y ที่ transform S ไปเป็น fi กล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่ง แม้ว่าสิ่งเหล่านี้เป็น
purifications ของ row ที่ arbitrary และเราไม่สมมติอะไรเกี่ยวกับพวกมันนอกจากว่าทั้งคู่ purify row และทั้งคู่เป็น
states ของ compound system XY เดียวกัน พวกมันต้องเทียบเท่ากันในแง่หนึ่ง โดย unitary operation บน Y
เพียงอย่างเดียว เราจะเห็นตัวอย่างบางส่วนที่แสดงให้เห็นว่าทำไมสิ่งนี้น่าสนใจและมีผลอะไรบ้าง แต่ก่อนอื่น
ดูว่าทำไมมันถึงเป็นจริง เริ่มด้วย spectral decomposition ของ row ซึ่งก็คือ
density matrix ที่ทั้ง S และ fi purify และเช่นเดียวกับที่ทำเมื่อพูดถึง Schmidt decomposition เรา
จะสมมติว่าเราได้ทิ้ง terms ทั้งหมดที่สอดคล้องกับ eigenvalues ศูนย์ ดังนั้น p 0 ถึง p R ลบ 1
ล้วนเป็นตัวเลขจริงบวก x0 ถึง xR ลบ 1 เป็น orthonormal eigenvectors ของ row และ R บังเอิญเป็น
rank ของ row และโดยวิธี เพียงเป็นการกล่าวแย้ง สังเกตว่าเราหยิบ spectral theorem มาใช้บ่อยแค่ไหน ณ จุดนี้
มันเป็นเครื่องมือที่มีประโยชน์อย่างเหลือเชื่อ และจริงๆ แล้วเราจะสูญเสียมากถ้าไม่มีมัน ไม่ว่าจะอย่างไรก็ตาม ตอนนี้ที่เรามี spectral
decomposition ของ row เราสามารถ compute Schmidt decompositions ของ vectors สองตัวของเราเช่นเดิม และมันจะ
เกือบเหมือนกันทุกอย่าง coefficients และ X vectors เหมือนกันเพราะมาจาก spectral decomposition ของ reduced state ซึ่ง
เหมือนกันสำหรับทั้งสอง vectors ความแตกต่างเดียวคืออาจได้ vectors ต่างกันสำหรับ second system สำหรับ
vector แรกคือ S เราจะได้ชุด vectors หนึ่งคือ y0 ถึง y R ลบ 1 และสำหรับ vector ที่สองคือ fi เราจะ
ได้ collection ที่อาจต่างกันซึ่งเราเรียกว่า z0 ถึง z R ลบ 1 ดังนั้นตอนนี้เรามี Schmidt decompositions
สำหรับ vectors สองตัวของเราซึ่งดูคล้ายมากยกเว้น vectors ของ second system อาจต่างกัน แต่สิ่ง
เหล่านี้เป็น Schmidt decompositions ดังนั้นทั้งสอง collections นี้ orthonormal และเราสามารถเลือก
unitary matrix U ที่ส่ง ya ไปยัง za สำหรับแต่ละ a ได้เสมอ unitary
operations จริงๆ แล้วเทียบเท่ากับ linear maps ที่ transform orthonormal basis หนึ่งไปยังอีกอัน และถ้า
สองชุดนี้ไม่ span space ทั้งหมดที่สอดคล้องกับ Y เราสามารถ extend ทั้งคู่ให้เป็น orthonormal
bases ได้เสมอโดยใช้ Gram-Schmidt orthogonalization procedure และนั่นคือวิธีที่ unitary
equivalence ของ purifications ถูกพิสูจน์ ในบทเรียนที่ 4 ของซีรีส์ เราพูดถึง superdense coding protocol
ซึ่งอนุญาตให้ผู้ส่งถ่ายโอน 2 classical bits ไปยังผู้รับโดยส่ง 1 qubit โดยต้นทุน 1 ebit ของ
shared entanglement ดังนั้นฉันสมมติว่าคุณคุ้นเคยกับ protocol นั้นแล้ว และจุดประสงค์ของตัวอย่างนี้คืออธิบาย
อย่างย่อว่ามันเชื่อมต่อกับ unitary equivalence ของ purifications อย่างไร จำว่าวิธีที่
protocol ทำงานคือ Alice และ Bob share ebit หรือกล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่ง phi plus Bell state Alice เลือก transform
Bell state นั้นไปเป็น Bell state ใดๆ ในสี่ตัว ขึ้นอยู่กับ 2 bits ที่เธอต้องการส่ง แล้วเธอส่ง
qubit ของเธอไปยัง Bob และเขาวัดเพื่อดูว่าเขามี Bell state ไหน สังเกตว่า Bell states ทั้งสี่ตัว
ให้ reduced state เดียวกันสำหรับ qubit ของ Bob คือ completely mixed state และจริงๆ แล้วนั่นพอแล้ว
ที่จะสรุปว่า superdense coding เป็นไปได้ Bell states ทั้งสี่ purify completely mixed state ดังนั้นโดย unitary
equivalence ของ purifications เราทราบว่าต้องเป็นไปได้สำหรับ Alice ที่จะ transform phi plus Bell state ไปเป็น
อีกสามตัวโดย apply unitary operation บน qubit ของเธอ แน่นอนว่ามันไม่ยากที่จะหา unitary operations ที่
ได้ผลจริงๆ และมันง่ายมาก แต่น่าสนใจอยู่ดีว่าเราสามารถสรุปได้ว่าสิ่งนี้
เป็นไปได้โดยไม่ต้องคิดเกี่ยวกับ unitary operations เลย และยิ่งไปกว่านั้นเราสามารถสรุปได้
ว่า generalizations ของ superdense coding ไปยังระบบที่ใหญ่กว่าเป็นไปได้ ตราบเท่าที่เรามีวิธี generalize Bell states ไปยังระบบที่ใหญ่กว่า
เพื่อให้ทุกอันให้ completely mixed state เป็น reduced state ของ Bob และจริงๆ แล้วมีวิธีที่รู้จักต่างๆ ในการทำ
นั้น setting ที่ต่างออกไปซึ่ง unitary equivalence ของ purifications มีผลคือ quantum
cryptography และผลที่สำคัญที่สุดอย่างหนึ่งคือมันตัดความเป็นไปได้ของการมีอยู่ของ Quantum protocol ที่ secure อย่างไม่มีเงื่อนไขสำหรับ
cryptographic primitive ที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ bit commitment ดังนั้น bit commitment คืออะไร bit commitment คือตัวอย่าง
ของ cryptographic primitive ซึ่งหมายถึง task หรือ procedure ระดับต่ำที่ให้ functionality พื้นฐานบางอย่างที่
สามารถใช้เป็น building block เพื่อทำสิ่งที่น่าสนใจกว่า เช่น การสร้าง digital signature schemes หรือ
zero knowledge protocols เป็นต้น ในกรณีของ bit commitment functionality พื้นฐานคือ
player Alice สามารถ commit ต่อค่าไบนารีที่เธอเลือกให้ player ที่สอง Bob แต่การเลือกของเธอยังคงซ่อนอยู่
จนกว่าเธอจะเลือกเปิดเผย เราต้องการคุณสมบัติสองอย่างเฉพาะจาก protocol ที่ implement bit
commitment มันต้อง binding ซึ่งหมายความว่า Alice ไม่สามารถเปลี่ยนใจหลังจาก commit bit แล้ว และ
ต้อง concealing ซึ่งหมายความว่า Bob ไม่สามารถรู้ bit ของ Alice จนกว่าเธอจะเลือกเปิดเผย
ดังนั้นมันน่าจะดีมากถ้าสามารถ implement primitive นี้โดยใช้ quantum information เพราะมันเป็น
primitive ที่มีประโยชน์ แต่โดยไม่มี assumptions เพิ่มเติม ปรากฏว่าเป็นไปไม่ได้ที่จะทำมันอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบด้วย quantum information หรือแม้แต่ใกล้
เคียง และ unitary equivalence ของ purifications เผยให้เห็นสิ่งนั้น แนวคิดในระดับ high level คือ
ถ้ามี quantum protocol สำหรับ bit commitment ก็ต้องมีสิ่งที่เรียกว่า purified version ของ protocol นั้น ซึ่งเราจินตนาการว่า
Alice มีระบบ A Bob มีระบบ B และหลังจาก commitment ถูกทำแต่ก่อน Alice เปิดเผย คู่ AB อยู่ใน
หนึ่งในสอง pure states คือ psi 0 หรือ psi 1 ขึ้นอยู่กับ bit ที่ Alice
commits ถ้า protocol perfectly concealing ก็ต้องเป็นที่ Bob ไม่สามารถแยกความแตกต่างระหว่างสอง
commitments ได้ ดังนั้น reduced state ของเขาต้องเหมือนกันสำหรับสองความเป็นไปได้ อย่างไรก็ตามนั่นหมายความว่าโดย
unitary equivalence ของ purifications Alice สามารถ transform อันใดอันหนึ่งไปยังอีกอันโดย apply unitary
operation บน A เพียงอย่างเดียว ดังนั้น protocol ล้มเหลวที่จะ binding โดยสิ้นเชิง มีรายละเอียดที่ฉัน
ละไว้ แต่แก่นของเรื่องคือ unitary equivalence ของ purifications บอกเราว่า primitive นี้ไม่ใช่สิ่งที่
เราสามารถ implement อย่างน่าเชื่อถือโดยใช้ quantum information โดยไม่มี assumptions เพิ่มเติมบางอย่าง
ตัวอย่างสุดท้ายของผลของ unitary equivalence ของ purifications คือ theorem ที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ
Hughston-Jozsa-Wootters theorem หรือ HJW theorem สำหรับย่อ เริ่มด้วย statement ของ
theorem เอง และนี่เป็น version ที่ simplified เล็กน้อยเพื่อหลีกเลี่ยงรายละเอียดทางเทคนิคเพื่อให้เราโฟกัสที่
แนวคิดหลัก สมมติว่า X และ Y เป็นระบบ และ fi เป็น quantum state vector ใดๆ แสดง pure state ของคู่
XY และตอนนี้สมมติว่าเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ reduced state ของระบบ X เพียงอย่างเดียว และเรามีวิธีใดๆ ที่เรา
เลือกแสดง reduced state นี้เป็น convex combination ของ pure states ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ
ตัวอย่างเช่น จำนวน N ตัวใหญ่ใน expression นี้ซึ่งคือจำนวน pure states ที่เรากำลัง average อาจ
ใหญ่มากได้ อาจใหญ่กว่า dimension ของ space ที่สอดคล้องกับ X หรือ Y มาก
และสิ่งที่ theorem บอกเราคือต้องมีการวัดบนระบบ Y ที่มี N outcomes เช่นว่า
สิ่งต่อไปนี้เกิดขึ้น เมื่อระบบ Y ถูกวัด ก่อนอื่น แต่ละ measurement outcome
ปรากฏด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับความน่าจะเป็นที่สอดคล้องกันใน expression ของ reduced state ของ X เป็น
convex combination ของ pure states และประการที่สอง ขึ้นอยู่กับการได้ measurement outcome หนึ่งๆ
state ของ X กลายเป็น pure state ที่สอดคล้องกันจาก convex combination ดังนั้นทำไมถึง
น่าสนใจ มันหมายความว่าสำหรับวิธีใดๆ ที่เราเลือกคิดเกี่ยวกับ reduced state ของ X เป็น convex
combination ของ pure states มีการวัดบางอย่างของ Y ที่ทำให้วิธีคิดเกี่ยวกับ reduced state ของ X แบบนี้
เป็นความจริง และสิ่งที่น่าทึ่งคือสิ่งนี้เป็นไปได้แม้ว่า state fi ถูกเลือกก่อนและ convex
combination ถูกเลือกทีหลัง ตราบเท่าที่มันเป็น expression ของ reduced state ของ X ก็จะมี
การวัดของ Y ที่ทำงานแบบนี้พอดี ดังนั้นดูว่าเราจะพิสูจน์
สิ่งนี้ได้อย่างไร เราเริ่มด้วย expressions สองแบบที่ต่างกันสำหรับ reduced ของ X ซึ่งเรียกว่า row เพื่อ
ความสะดวก ต่อไปเราแนะนำระบบใหม่ Z ที่ classical states เป็น measurement outcomes ที่เป็นไปได้ หรือ
เทียบเท่ากับ indices ใน convex combination และตอนนี้เราสังเกตได้ว่า quantum state vectors สองตัวต่อไปนี้
gamma 0 และ Gamma 1 ซึ่งทั้งคู่เป็น state vectors ของ compound system XYZ
ทั้งคู่เป็น purifications ของ row และเพื่อความชัดเจน เมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ vectors เหล่านี้ว่าเป็น purifications ของ row เรา
คิดเกี่ยวกับระบบ Y และ Z ร่วมกันเป็น compound system เดียวที่ถูก trace out เพื่อเหลือ
row vector แรก gamma 0 นั้นเหมือนกับ pure state fi เดิมโดยพื้นฐานยกเว้นว่าเรา
initialize ระบบใหม่ Z ไปที่ zero state มันชัดเจนว่าถ้าเรา trace out Y และ Z เราจะเหลือ row ดังนั้น gamma
0 เป็น purification ของ row vector ที่สอง Gamma 1 โดยพื้นฐานคือ vector ที่ได้จากการ purify
row โดยใช้ convex combination ตามที่ฉันอธิบายก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน ครั้งนี้ระบบ Y ถูก
initialize และฉันสมมติเพื่อความเรียบง่ายว่า zero เป็น classical state ของ Y แต่คุณสามารถแทนที่ standard basis state ใดๆ
หรือจริงๆ pure state ใดๆ ของ Y ใน expression นี้ได้ และไม่ต่างกัน ไม่ว่าจะอย่างไร การ trace out Y และ
Z อีกครั้งทิ้ง row ไว้ ดังนั้น bottom line คือทั้งสองนี้เป็น purifications ของ row และดังนั้นโดย
unitary equivalence ของ purifications มี unitary operation U บนคู่ YZ ที่ transform gamma 0 ไปเป็น
Gamma 1 และนั่นคือทุกสิ่งที่เราต้องการเพื่อคิด description ของการวัดที่ทำตามที่ theorem
บอก วิธีง่ายในการอธิบายคือด้วย circuit diagram ตามที่แสดงที่นี่บนหน้าจอ ใน words เราเริ่มด้วย
state fi เรา introduce Z initialized ไปที่ zero state perform U จากนั้นวัด top system ซึ่งก็คือ Z ด้วย
standard basis measurement โดยพื้นฐานแล้วสิ่งที่ทำคือ transform fi ไปเป็น Gamma 1 และ
เพียงแค่ดูที่ description ของ Gamma 1 เราเห็นว่ามันทำตามที่ theorem บอก คือเราได้
แต่ละ outcome a ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น PA และ conditioned บนการได้ a ระบบ X ถูกเหลือไว้ใน state sa
และเพื่อความชัดเจน การวัดเองที่ theorem แสดงการมีอยู่ถูก implement โดย
ทุกอย่างใน dotted rectangle ในรูป และถ้าต้องการรู้ว่าการวัด
สามารถอธิบายเป็น collection ของ matrices ได้อย่างไร นี่คือ expression ของมัน ฉันจะไม่อธิบายส่วนนี้ และ
มันไม่สำคัญจริงๆ สำหรับตัวอย่าง แต่นั่นคือ expression ของ measurement matrices ในกรณีที่
สนใจ ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึง Fidelity ซึ่งเป็นตัววัดความคล้ายคลึงของ quantum states สองตัว หรืออีกทางหนึ่ง
ว่า overlap ของพวกมัน เราจะเริ่มด้วย definition ซึ่งอาจดูลึกลับเล็กน้อยใน
มองแรก แต่เราจะอธิบาย และเมื่อสิ้นสุดการพูดถึงหวังว่าจะโน้มน้าวให้คุณเห็นว่ามัน
จริงๆ แล้วเป็น function ที่ดีกว่าที่ดูเผินๆ และนี่คือ
definition Fidelity ระหว่าง density matrices สองตัวคือ row และ sigma เท่ากับ trace ของ square root ของ
square root ของ row คูณ sigma คูณ square root ของ row เราจะพูดถึงมัน
ก่อนอื่น ลองทำความเข้าใจ definition เอง เรามี square roots สามตัวและ
ทั้งหมดหมายถึง square root ของ positive semi-definite matrix ซึ่งตามที่เราพูดถึงในบทเรียนก่อนหน้าคือ
positive semi-definite matrix เฉพาะที่กำลังสองให้ matrix ที่เรา take square root เพราะ
row เป็น density matrix มันต้องเป็น positive semi-definite ดังนั้นเราสามารถ take root ของมันได้ และถ้าคิดเกี่ยวกับ root ของ row คูณ
sigma คูณ root ของ row สักครู่ เราเห็นว่ามันก็ positive semi-definite ด้วย และโดยเฉพาะเราสามารถเขียนมันเป็น
M dagger คูณ M สำหรับ M เป็น square root ของ sigma คูณ square root ของ row และดังนั้นเราสามารถ take square
root ของมันได้ โดยเฉพาะเราสามารถ compute spectral decomposition ของ root ของ
row คูณ sigma คูณ root ของ row และจากนั้นเพื่อ take square root เราแค่ต้อง take square roots ของ eigen
values และปล่อย eigenvectors ไว้ และสุดท้ายเรา take trace ของ
matrix นี้ และเพราะ trace เท่ากับผลรวมของ eigenvalues เราได้ expression ที่เรามีอยู่
ที่นี่ ดังนั้นนั่นน่าจะเป็นสิ่งที่คุณไม่อยาก compute ด้วยมือโดยทั่วไป และคำอธิบายนี้อาจไม่
ให้ insight มากนักเกี่ยวกับ Fidelity หรือทำไมเราถึงสนใจมัน แต่หวังว่ามันจะชี้แจง
ความหมายทางเทคนิคของ formula โดยวิธี เป็นการกล่าวแย้ง บางครั้งผู้คน define Fidelity ให้
เป็น square ของ function ที่ฉัน define ที่นี่ และพวกเขาเรียก function นี้ว่า root
Fidelity คุณจะเห็นมัน define ทั้งสองแบบ ซึ่งแน่นอนมีความเป็นไปได้ที่จะทำให้สับสน แต่โดยปกติไม่ค่อย
เพราะผู้คนมักค่อนข้างระมัดระวังในการชี้แจง definition ที่ใช้ และคุณควร
ทำสิ่งเดียวกัน ในสายตาของฉันจริงๆ ไม่มี definition ที่ถูกหรือผิด ฉัน define มัน
แบบนี้เพียงเพราะฉันชินกับการทำแบบนี้ และฉันพบว่ามันสะดวกกว่านิดหน่อย เดาว่าเพราะฉันอยากจะกำลังสอง
สิ่งบางอย่างมากกว่า take square root ในภายหลังเมื่อต้องการ แต่แน่นอนคุณสามารถเลือกเองได้
แต่ไม่ว่าจะอย่างไร กลับมาที่ Fidelity ตามที่ define ที่นี่ มีวิธีอื่นที่เทียบเท่าในการ
define Fidelity และจริงๆ แล้วมันเป็น function ที่น่าทึ่งในแง่นั้น และสามารถระบุลักษณะได้ในวิธีที่น่าสนใจพอสมควร
นี่คือวิธีที่ค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาในการเขียน definition ใหม่ในรูปของ trace norm ซึ่งเราเห็นในช่วง
ท้ายของบทเรียนก่อนหน้า ฉันไม่ได้ลงรายละเอียดมากเกินไปเกี่ยวกับ trace norm และโดยเฉพาะ
ฉันไม่ได้แม้แต่ define มันสำหรับ matrices ที่ไม่ Hermitian แต่มันมี definition ที่ง่ายพอ วิธีหนึ่งในการ define trace norm ของ
matrix M ใดๆ คือ trace ของ square root ของ M คูณ M dagger หรือเทียบเท่าคือ trace ของ square
root ของ M dagger คูณ M ได้ค่าเดียวกันไม่ว่าจะทำแบบไหน และเราสามารถใช้ definition นั้นเพื่อ simplify
definition ของ Fidelity ตามที่มีด้านล่างของหน้าจอ และนั่นดีเพราะมันเผยให้เห็นว่า
มัน symmetric ใน arguments สองตัว เรายังสามารถแสดง trace norm ของ square matrix M เป็น
maximum ของ absolute value ของ trace ของ M คูณ U ranging over unitary matrices U ทั้งหมด ซึ่งไม่ชัดเจน แต่
เป็นจริง และนั่นให้เรา expression อื่นสำหรับ Fidelity ดังนั้นเรามีสาม
definitions ที่เทียบเท่ากันสำหรับ Fidelity และนั่นเป็นแค่จุดเริ่มต้น มีอีกหลาย definitions ที่เทียบเท่าอื่นๆ และ
เราจะเห็นหนึ่งที่สำคัญมากซึ่งมาจาก Uhlmann's theorem ในช่วงท้ายของบทเรียน
โอเค ดังนั้นนั่นดี แต่มันหมายความว่าอะไรในระดับ intuitive และทำไมเราถึงสนใจ
function นี้ เพื่อตอบคำถามเหล่านี้ มันเป็นประโยชน์ที่จะพิจารณา special case ที่อย่างน้อยหนึ่งในสอง density
matrices แสดง pure state ถ้าทั้งสอง states เป็น pure แล้ว
Fidelity ก็แค่ absolute value ของ inner product ระหว่าง quantum state vectors สองตัว และในบางแง่
นี่คือแรงจูงใจหลักสำหรับ Fidelity เอง absolute value ของ inner product ระหว่าง quantum state
vectors สองตัวเป็นตัวเลขระหว่างศูนย์และหนึ่งเสมอ และให้วิธีธรรมชาติในการวัด overlap ระหว่าง
quantum state vectors สองตัว และคุณสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ Fidelity ว่าเป็นวิธีที่มีประโยชน์และ well-behaved ใน
การ extend วิธีวัด overlap นี้จาก pure states ไปยัง density matrices ถ้า state หนึ่งเป็น pure
และอีก state ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็น pure ก็จะมี expression ง่ายๆ อีกครั้งสำหรับ Fidelity ซึ่งอาจ
มีประโยชน์มาก และ expression นั้นแสดงอยู่ที่นี่ Fidelity มีหลาย
properties ที่น่าสนใจ และนั่นเป็นเหตุผลหนึ่งที่ผู้คนใช้มัน มัน definition ที่ไม่ค่อย
nice แต่มันเป็น function ที่มีประโยชน์มาก และมักใช้ง่ายมาก ส่วนหนึ่งเพราะ properties มากมายที่น่าทึ่งของมัน
ดังนั้นดูบางส่วนจากพวกมัน เริ่มด้วยการสังเกตว่า Fidelity ระหว่าง density
matrices สองตัวเป็นตัวเลขระหว่าง 0 ถึง 1 เสมอ มันเป็นศูนย์ก็ต่อเมื่อ states
orthogonal ซึ่งหมายความว่า images เป็น orthogonal subspaces หรือเทียบเท่าที่ product ของ matrices สองตัวเป็น
ศูนย์ และ Fidelity เป็นหนึ่งก็ต่อเมื่อ density matrices สองตัวเท่ากัน ทุกกรณีอื่นอยู่ที่ไหนสักแห่งระหว่าง
แต่ intuitive แล้ว ยิ่ง Fidelity ใกล้หนึ่งมากเท่าไหร่ states ก็ยิ่งคล้ายกันมากขึ้น หรืออีกทางหนึ่ง
ยิ่ง overlap มากขึ้น Fidelity ยัง symmetric ฉันพูดถึงเรื่องนั้นเมื่อสักครู่ มัน
ค่อนข้างชัดเจนจาก expression ที่เราเห็นสำหรับ Fidelity ในรูปของ trace norm แต่มันสำคัญที่จะตระหนัก
อย่างไรก็ตาม ต่อไป Fidelity เป็น multiplicative สำหรับ product states หมายความว่า Fidelity ระหว่างสอง
product states เท่ากับผลคูณของ fidelities ระหว่าง
states แต่ละตัว นี่คือ property ที่มีประโยชน์มาก ถ้าเรามี density matrices ขนาดเดียวกันสองตัว
พร้อมกับ channel ใดๆ ที่รับ density matrices เหล่านี้เป็น input Fidelity จะเพิ่มขึ้นเท่านั้นเมื่อ channel
นั้นถูก apply กับทั้งสอง states กล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่งในรูปของ Fidelity channels สามารถทำให้ states
คล้ายกันมากขึ้นเท่านั้น ไม่สามารถทำให้คล้ายกันน้อยลงได้ และสุดท้ายสำหรับรายการนี้
มีความสัมพันธ์ใกล้ชิดระหว่าง Fidelity และ trace distance ระหว่าง states ซึ่ง define
เป็นครึ่งหนึ่งของ trace norm ของความต่างระหว่าง density matrices สองตัว trace distance ระหว่าง
states เชื่อมโยงอย่างแน่นแฟ้นกับว่าเราสามารถแยกแยะพวกมันได้ดีแค่ไหน ซึ่งเราพูดถึงในบทเรียนก่อนหน้าในบริบทของ
state discrimination และ Helstrom-Holevo theorem ในขณะที่ Fidelity quantify ว่า states สองตัว
overlap กันมากแค่ไหน ดังนั้นแม้ว่าพวกมันไม่เหมือนกันทุกอย่าง ก็ไม่น่าแปลกใจที่มีความสัมพันธ์ระหว่าง
quantities สองตัวนี้ แต่ไม่ว่าจะอย่างไร inequalities เหล่านี้ซึ่งเรียกกันทั่วไปว่า Fuchs-van de Graaf inequalities
ทำให้ความสัมพันธ์นี้ precise ทางคณิตศาสตร์ และมันสำคัญมากที่ไม่มีการพึ่งพาขนาดของระบบที่เราพูดถึงเลย
เราสามารถเห็นความสัมพันธ์นี้ชัดขึ้นอีกนิดด้วยความช่วยเหลือของรูป ถ้าเรามีสอง states และเรา
ระบุ trace distance ระหว่างพวกมันบน x-axis และ Fidelity บน y-axis เส้นแนวตั้ง
และแนวนอนที่สอดคล้องกันต้องตัดกันที่ไหนสักแห่งภายใน gray region นี้ region ที่น่าสนใจที่สุด
ของ plot โดยวิธี อย่างน้อยในเชิงปฏิบัติคือมุมบนซ้ายของ gray region โดยเฉพาะเมื่อ
trace distance เล็กมาก Fidelity ต้องใกล้หนึ่งมากและในทางกลับกัน
inequalities เหล่านี้ถูกใช้บ่อยมาก และส่วนหนึ่งของเหตุผลนั้นคือเรามักสนใจ trace
distance มากกว่าในที่สุดเพราะมัน interpretation ธรรมชาติที่เชื่อมกับ quantum state discrimination
แต่ Fidelity มี properties ที่น่าทึ่งมากมายจนโดยทั่วไปมันเป็นตัวที่ใช้งานง่ายกว่า และตราบเท่าที่เราอยู่ในมุมบนซ้ายของ
gray region ซึ่งมักเป็นที่ที่เราพบตัวเอง เราไม่เสียอะไรมากนักจากการแปลงกลับไปกลับมาระหว่าง Fidelity และ trace distance ดังนั้น
นั่นคือ properties บางส่วนของ Fidelity ยังมีอีกมาก แต่เป็นจุดเริ่มต้นที่ดี และหวังว่ารายการจะ
มีประโยชน์สำหรับเริ่มพัฒนา intuition เกี่ยวกับ Fidelity นี่คือตัวอย่างที่ดีว่าเรา
สามารถเชื่อม Fidelity กับการวัดแบบ non-destructive ได้อย่างไร มันเป็น fact ที่มีประโยชน์มากที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ gentle measurement
lemma สมมติว่าเรามีระบบ X state ของ X แสดงโดย density matrix row และการวัดบนระบบ X
ที่อธิบายโดย collection ของ positive semi-definite matrices สมมติว่า measurement outcome หนึ่งมีแนวโน้ม
สูงมากที่จะปรากฏถ้าเราทำการวัดบน state row เพื่อความเรียบง่าย สมมติว่า
เป็น outcome Z ที่มีโอกาสสูง และโดยเฉพาะสมมติว่า outcome นี้ปรากฏด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
มากกว่า 1 ลบ epsilon สำหรับค่าเล็กๆ ของ epsilon ที่เราไม่จำเป็นต้องระบุ epsilon
เป็นแค่ตัวเลขจริงบวกเล็กๆ ตอนนี้เราได้อธิบายการวัดเหมือนว่ามันเป็น destructive
measurement แต่เราทราบจากบทเรียนก่อนหน้าว่าเราสามารถ implement การวัดนี้แบบ non-destructive ได้ และโดยเฉพาะเราสามารถทำได้
ตามที่เราเห็นในการพูดถึง Naimark's theorem และมันทำงานแบบนี้ แต่ละ outcome a ปรากฏด้วย
ความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ trace ของ PA คูณ row และ conditioned บนการได้ outcome นั้น state ของ X เปลี่ยนใน
แบบหนึ่ง โดยเฉพาะในกรณีที่ได้ outcome ที่น่าจะเป็นคือ zero state จะกลายเป็น square root ของ p 0 คูณ row คูณ square root ของ p 0
ทั้งหมด normalized เพื่อให้ได้ density matrix และสิ่งที่ gentle measurement lemma บอกเราคือในเหตุการณ์นี้
ซึ่งหมายความว่าเราได้ measurement outcome ที่น่าจะเป็นจริงๆ state ที่ได้จะไม่เปลี่ยนแปลงมากนักจาก
ต้นฉบับ และโดยเฉพาะ Fidelity กำลังสองจะต้องใหญ่กว่า 1 ลบ
epsilon อย่างจำเป็น และนี่ดีมากเพราะมัน general ทั้งหมด เราไม่ได้บอกอะไรเลยเกี่ยวกับการวัดหรือ
state นอกจากว่า outcome หนึ่งมีโอกาสสูง ดังนั้น lemma สามารถ apply ได้ใน
หลาย settings ที่เราต้องการตรวจสอบบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับ quantum state โดยไม่รบกวนมากนัก ดังนั้นดูว่าเราจะพิสูจน์
มันได้อย่างไร และโดยส่วนใหญ่มันเป็นการ calculate Fidelity ระหว่าง pre และ post-measurement
states ที่ค่อนข้างง่าย เราสามารถทำได้โดยใช้ definition ต้นฉบับ และโดยปกติอาจเหลือ formula ยุ่งๆ แต่
ในกรณีนี้เราโชคดีเพราะสิ่งอยู่ข้างใน outer square root จริงๆ แล้วคือ square ของ matrix ที่
บังเอิญ positive semi-definite ซึ่งทำให้การ compute square root ง่ายมาก ตอนนี้เราสามารถใช้ cyclic
property ของ trace พร้อมกับ linearity ของ trace เพื่อ simplify expression ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ สังเกตว่า
ทั้งหมดนี้เป็น equalities ดังนั้นเราไม่ได้ approximate อะไรในตอนนี้ เรา simplify จริงๆ แต่ตอนนี้เราต้องการ
inequality เพราะเราต้องการกำจัด square root ใน numerator และเราสามารถทำได้จริงๆ ถ้าเราพอใจกับ lower bound และถ้า
สนใจรายละเอียดส่วนนี้ คุณสามารถได้ inequality ค่อนข้างง่ายโดยพิจารณา spectral decomposition ของ p
0 eigenvalues ของ p 0 ต้องอยู่ระหว่าง 0 ถึง 1 ซึ่งเป็นจริงเสมอสำหรับ matrices ที่อธิบาย
measurements และเมื่อเราทราบนั้น inequality ตามมาค่อนข้างตรงจาก fact ที่ว่าการ take square root ของ
ตัวเลขระหว่าง 0 ถึง 1 ทำให้มันใหญ่ขึ้นเท่านั้น อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดคือการยกกำลังสองตัวเลขระหว่าง 0 ถึง
1 ทำให้มันเล็กลงเท่านั้น ตอนนี้เราสามารถ simplify อีกนิดหน่อย และเราได้ square
root ของ trace ของ p 0 คูณ row สุดท้ายการยกกำลังสองทั้งสองด้านและ
แทน bound ของความน่าจะเป็นให้เราได้สิ่งที่ต้องการ ดังนั้น formula สำหรับ Fidelity
ไม่ใช่ formula ที่ nice หรือใช้ง่ายที่สุดในโลก แต่ที่นี่มัน
ทำงานได้ค่อนข้างดี เพื่อสรุปบทเรียน เราจะดู Uhlmann's theorem ซึ่งเป็น fact พื้นฐานเกี่ยวกับ Fidelity ที่
เชื่อมมันกับ notion ของ purification สิ่งที่ theorem บอกในรูปแบบง่ายๆ คือ Fidelity ระหว่าง quantum states สองตัวใดๆ
เท่ากับ maximum inner product ใน absolute value ระหว่าง purifications สองตัวของ
states เหล่านั้น ในรายละเอียดมากขึ้น สมมติว่า row และ sigma เป็น density matrices สำหรับระบบ X บางตัว และสมมติว่า Y เป็น
ระบบที่มี classical states อย่างน้อยเท่ากับ X และดังนั้นรับประกันว่าทั้งสอง states มี purifications ที่เป็น
quantum state vectors ของ XY เราจึงสามารถแสดง implication ของ theorem ในรูปแบบ equation
ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ Fidelity ระหว่าง row และ sigma เท่ากับ maximum absolute value ของ inner product
ระหว่าง fi และ S ranging over fi และ S ทั้งหมดที่ purify row และ sigma
ตามลำดับ ดังนั้น clean สิ่งนี้ขึ้นและทำงานกับ precise mathematical statement ต่อไป สิ่งที่เราจะทำตอนนี้คือพิสูจน์
theorem แต่ก่อนอื่นคุ้มค่าที่จะใช้เวลาสักครู่เพื่อชื่นชมว่ามันให้วิธีที่ค่อนข้าง intuitive ในการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
Fidelity นอกจากนี้ยังมีประโยชน์ค่อนข้างมากในตัวมันเอง ตัวอย่างเช่น เพื่อพิสูจน์สิ่งที่น่าสนใจยิ่งขึ้นเกี่ยวกับ
Fidelity เพื่อพิสูจน์มัน เราจะเริ่มด้วย spectral decompositions ของ density matrices ของเรา
ไม่มีอะไรน่าประหลาดใจตรงนั้น เมื่อเรามี spectral decompositions มันง่ายในการหา
purifications เฉพาะสองตัวของ states เหล่านี้ แต่ที่นี่เราจะใช้
เคล็ดลับ สังเกตว่าในทั้งสองกรณีเราไม่มี standard basis vector เป็น second tensor factor อย่างที่ทำก่อนหน้าใน
บทเรียน แต่เรามี vector เดียวกับใน first tensor factor ยกเว้นว่ามันมี bar อยู่เหนือมัน และ
นั่นหมายถึง entry-wise complex conjugate ของ vectors เหล่านี้ กล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่งเราแค่ take
second copy ของ eigenvectors แต่ take complex conjugate ของแต่ละ entry และเราจะเห็นว่าทำไมเราทำนั้นในอีก
สักครู่ แต่ไม่ชัดเจนเลยว่าควรทำสิ่งนี้ และนั่นคือทำไมเราถึงเรียกมันว่า
เคล็ดลับ ไม่ว่าจะอย่างไรก็ตาม สิ่งเหล่านี้เป็น purifications ของ row และ sigma ตามลำดับ และนั่นเป็นจริงโดยอาศัย
fact ที่ว่า eigenvectors ของเราเป็น orthonormal และดังนั้น complex conjugates ที่ entry-wise ของพวกมันก็เช่นกัน และตอนนี้เราสามารถ apply
unitary equivalence ของ purifications ซึ่งบอกว่าทุก purification ของ states สองตัวของเราสามารถได้มาโดย
การ apply unitary operation กับระบบที่ถูก trace out สำหรับการเลือก purifications เฉพาะที่
เพิ่งทำ unitary operations ไม่จำเป็นต้องเหมือนกันสำหรับ purifications สองตัว
แน่นอน ดังนั้นที่นี่เราใช้ตัวอักษร U สำหรับตัวแรกและตัวอักษร V สำหรับตัว
ที่สอง ดังนั้น point คือทุก purification ของ states สองตัวของเราสามารถเขียนได้ตามที่มีบนหน้าจอ สำหรับ
การเลือก unitary operations U และ V บางอย่าง และตอนนี้เราสามารถ take expression
จาก theorem และ simplify ถ้าเรา plug in expressions ของ fi และ S และ simplify นิดหน่อย เรา
ได้ expression ที่แสดงที่นี่บนหน้าจอ ตอนนี้มีขั้นตอนสองสามอย่างในนั้นและฉันไม่ได้แสดงรายละเอียด
ดังนั้นคุณรู้ว่าต้องทำอะไรถ้าอยากทำ แต่ขอบอกว่าเหตุผลที่เราเลือก purifications ตามที่ทำ
คือเพื่อให้ inner product นี้ simplify ในแบบนี้พอดี และโดยเฉพาะเราใส่ complex conjugates
เข้าไปเพื่อให้สามารถ flip รอบๆ inner products ใน second tensor factor ได้เพื่อให้ได้รูปแบบ
เฉพาะที่เรามีที่นี่ เราเกือบถึงแล้ว ตอนนี้เราสามารถใช้ cyclic property ของ trace พร้อมกับ
spectral decompositions ที่เราเริ่มต้นด้วยเพื่อได้ expression นี้ และในจุดนี้เราสามารถ
ใช้หนึ่งในวิธีอื่นในการแสดง Fidelity โดยใช้ trace norm และเรา
เสร็จแล้ว แน่นอนมีรายละเอียดในนั้นที่ฉันข้ามไปอย่างรวดเร็ว และมันเป็น proof ชนิดที่คุณ
ต้องทำเองจริงๆ เพื่อเข้าใจอย่างสมบูรณ์ แต่หวังว่านี่ให้แนวคิดพื้นฐาน
และตามปกติคุณสามารถหารายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมในเนื้อหาที่เป็นลายลักษณ์อักษรสำหรับบทเรียนซึ่ง link อยู่ใน video
description และนั่นคือจุดสิ้นสุดของบทเรียนซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ purifications Fidelity และความเชื่อมต่อระหว่างพวกมัน และยัง
เป็นจุดสิ้นสุดของ unit ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ general formulation ของ quantum information หวังว่าคุณจะมาร่วม
unit ที่สี่และสุดท้ายของซีรีส์ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ quantum error correction ขอบคุณสำหรับการรับชม